[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from complex headquarters in beautiful
Los Angeles where we pulled out all the
stops for our buddy
comedian Tom Segura what do you think of
the kitchen setup here wow you guys went
out of your way someone just came in and
got their yogurt out of the fridge hope
they come back really really impressive
man thank you you know Tom from his
podcast your mom's house as well as his
Netflix stand-up special is completely
normal and mostly stories and good news
for comedy fans there's another one on
its way January 12th Tom and I are
meeting up here in Los Angeles arguably
the fast food capital of the country to
settle the age-old debate which
restaurant reigns supreme Shake Shack
versus in it out you know it's in and
out bro throwing up the west coast and
Tom before we dive into the patties I
have to say you're looking lean you're
looking mean how has your weight loss
competition with our buddy Bert
Kreischer worked out for you it's been
great man it's been a life-changing
event where we encouraged our own fans
to fat shame the other person and I
would say fat shaming is very effective
sometimes you do it alone you know you
look in the mirror you're like I'm a fat
piece of [ __ ] you know but when other
people are constantly telling you that
and you're welcoming it it's a it's a
reminder you go like I'm not gonna eat
like an [ __ ] today you know I know
that you've lived all over the country
you've been in Los Angeles now for a few
years have you been converted to the
cult of in and out hundred percent man
there's something about in and out that
should be celebrated no matter where
you're from I mean you go you order
fries they're [ __ ] slice and potatoes
you want a burger they stab a cow in the
parking lot they pay over minimum wage
you have happier you know better
honestly better-looking employees I
think that they do that you going to
Arby's it's like some guy with the
missing eyes bleeding out of his face
dude's face was like a torn softball
where do you stand on Shake Shack I've
had it's good but I I mean I'm I'm
bringing my bias to the tape
because it's honest it comes from a good
place I believe it is a superior product
in now but I am willing I haven't I
haven't dove as deep as we're going
today we're going very deep today I vow
to remain objective and to start things
out you can only begin in one place it's
the crinkle-cut versus the hand cut
let's bring out the fries alright so
here we are with two of the most iconic
fry orders in fast food you have
in-and-out animal style you have their
spread you have cheese you have onions
and then you have shake Shack's cheese
fries it's a mix of American and cheddar
cheese on top of this when you go to
in-and-out do you order at animal style
er no I like I said I haven't been
frequenting the fries that much lately
I've been doing protein style trying to
avoid the carbs go but if I'm like going
deep if I'm like it goes do it right
you've got to go animal style
absolutely it's the authentic in-and-out
experience and it is it is the authentic
experience I'm up for trying the Shake
Shack was I've never happy let's dive in
alright let's do it advance do it not
bad not bad at all they're very ballgame
they're very carnival to me crinkle cut
fries at Shake Shack to me they're very
nostalgic what is that that goat cheese
sauce it's a mixture of American and
cheddar and it is heavy it's heavy lost
and I would love to be drunk eating this
but not to be outdone when it comes to
drunk eats the animal style whole french
fries at in-and-out tell me you come
home from the bar yeah it's 3 a.m. yeah
and this is plopped down in front of you
oh my god I would 100% eat myself sick
of it did you get four for me and just
keep eating them until everything came
back up when you have this animal style
concoction but you end up doing this
with every fork full having basically a
fast food smoothie it's the taste that
you get from their burger just with a
different ingredient involved so you're
essentially keeping that burger train
rolling you're just enjoying more of it
with potatoes here's the thing if it's a
standalone fry argument I could see you
having the preference
but if you're talking about the
concoctions that have been made here
this is mfinney
the symphony of everything together I
feel like in and out is is winning this
battle alright Tom well we're not
starting off on all that contentious a
page on me same wavelength on this one
my nod on the fries in and out over the
cheese fries from Shake Shack
all right well Los Angeles is one of the
few places in the country where you can
get that Shack burger and you can get
the in-and-out single so we're gonna
take full advantage here so the Shack
burger is 100% all-natural Angus beef
served on a Martin's potato roll served
with lettuce tomato pickle and/or onion
when it comes to in-and-out you have
100% pure American beef the Shake Shack
burger is very like soft you know like
one of those things that you can just
sort of let melt in your mouth the Shake
Shack feels like almost like Hawaiian
bread right you know has that that
quality alright so same with you now to
me when you bite through I love that
smash burger style so 1950s it's such a
throwback you don't get that everywhere
it's just sort of a Shake Shack thing
where do you fall on it well I feel like
this tastes like how it feels like
you're eating almost like you're
cheating like you're not really eating a
full burger so like if I ate one of
these I'd be like do you have six more
and then here we are at in and out a
little bit fuller in the fact that you
have lettuce you have tomato you have
all this stuff coming out at you it's
fresh quality ingredients you know what
it really comes down to what does it
come down to it comes down to the spread
in other words that sauce if you like
the way that tastes you're you're in so
you're really I feel like your only case
against this if you're like I don't like
the way that sauce tastes then this is
not for you that's really it is the
Shake Shack hittin you a little bit
better than you thought it would you
have any expectations and they jump over
that bar yeah well our expectations were
is there was gonna be dog food so that's
that was kind of the way I was going
into it I was going in super pro West
Coast defending the honor of my city and
the bird
that we all use as fuel to get through
life here being actually no it
definitely exceeds my expectations I
actually think it's a damn tasty burger
think patty think bun think toppings
give us a nod and let me know why okay I
mean I'll say this I am in all honesty a
big fan of this Shake Shack but I like
that texture I like the way it squeezes
s like I could eat no 15 in a setting
and and not really not really think
twice until I'm on my way to the
hospital
so I would I really enjoy that with this
in and out though I mean it's also like
it's it's it's familiar to me it's
consistent like this burger never lets
me down it's always that way the bread
is always good the beef is fresh the
produce is fresh and I I mean I live
here bro we try to do man but get me
hurt the reason why Shake Shack reign
supreme is because of this smash burger
I crave it I love it so to me I'm given
the nod to Shake Shack what about you
are you a single patty guy are you a
double patty guy where do you fall there
man
I love my nuts gonna go all day go big
or go home come on I'm [ __ ] around
with a single my sons to you leaders
single and here we are approaching the
finish line the last stop is the secret
menu and we have two very interesting
items on our plate for in and out you
have the flying dutchman which is just
beef patties like their burger buns with
a couple of slices of cheese in between
and then here at Shake Shack we have a
very interesting item it is their peanut
butter bacon burger which is another off
menu item but first things first do you
ever go to where no man's gone before
when you go to in and out do you ever
pull back the curtain on that secret
menu dude I love it I mean the secret
menu makes you feel like you're in the
club right so it's a very cool thing
we're like this jackass doesn't know
what to get let me order it's like when
you know it's like you know the chef at
a restaurant you're like is Kevin can
you come out and you talk to them you
like fix us up a little nice right right
that does it for you yeah it's a Toli of
flex and then I guess we should just
dive in we'll start with the Flying
Dutchman
let's do it in the kitchen where you
know the ingredients are just kind of
what might be there you don't really
know you don't go grocery shopping all
that often you're a little high you need
to make something on the fly and you're
like what do I got we got I want to make
a burger you might throw together some
monstrosity like this but it tastes
amazing today is amazing I'm doing
Flying Dutchman for sure it's on the new
the new drive home
I'm Flying Dutchman all the way is that
say though no dignity in this there's no
dignity but there is a satisfaction in
just it you know what it is for a purist
man it's just the meat and the cheese
sometimes you don't want to deal with
anything else cut out the middleman cut
them out all right and then this one I'm
curious I'm interested in this peanut
butter on a bacon burger are you a
little nervous are you excited are you
intrigued what's going through your head
I am wildly hesitant that's what I would
say I am I I think that this is this
could go either way right now I feel
like it's like someone say hey do you
want a salmon milkshake and you're like
all right sure
that's all the dice it's better than I
thought it would be but I'm never gonna
have to ask it ever again as long as I
live
all right well I have a feeling where
you're going on the secret menu tom
where are you going I'm all in in and
out this Flying Dutchman is on my new
life menu you've done it again I have
nothing but love for in and out West
Coast for life putting this together in
my head Tom I have to give it to in and
out humbled coming from New York to say
that but at least I can come back to LA
and yeah you know get stabbed by Tom
Segura I would kill you if you voted the
other way right now and that'd be the
last video you ever made in and out it
has the crown until next time Internet
Sean Evans this is first we feast and
then this is Tom Segura thanks for
having me you're welcome
[Music]